they are
at the first ever shoot for Road say it
with me
road is finally here Haley Beaver
launched her skincare line this past
June with a special nod to her and her
mom road is my middle name it's my mom's
middle name to me always sounded like it
flowed so nicely Haley has always been
known for her very clean Beauty routines
going viral last year for her glazed
donut skincare Trend I love the idea of
your skin just looking like you want to
take a bite out of it so it only made
sense that road skincare launched with a
glazing fluid to get the look the whole
point behind the glaze is that it leaves
you looking like a delicious yummy
glazed donut obviously that's the goal
launch day started with Road skincare
selling out product after product I just
got news from The Meta team that the kit
is sold out it's gone and ended with her
appearing on The Tonight Show with Jimmy
Fallon to chat all about it I just felt
like over the last almost 10 years of
working in this industry I felt like I
was really able to develop my beauty
philosophy and I got to a point where I
was like
I want to make a curated edited line of
Essentials like my go-to things that can
work for everyone you said that uh when
you go to bed at night you want to feel
you want to look like a glaze you want
to give off the vibe of a glazed donut
you know what I mean
I want people to step into the world of
Road and feel included and feel like
they can be a part of it feel like they
can afford it feel like the stuff that
I'm using on my skin is the same thing
that you can use on your skin
[Music]